（Twitterを見ていて）
（私はふと思った）
Twitterのアイコン変えたいです、はじめしゃちょーです
Twitterのフォロワー様がお陰様で281万人いきました
ありがとうございます
日本6位です
前髪がすっごい短い時があったんですよアホみたいにね。
アホみたいに前髪短い時があったので
その時がいやすぎて
自分の変な前髪をなんとか払拭しようと
キャわいいこのアニメのアイコンにしたんですけども
前髪結構伸びて来たのでもうアイコン変えちゃってもいいのかなと思いまして
Twitterのアイコンを変えようと思います
という純粋な企画
いや大事ですよ
僕が皆さんとコミュニケーションを取れる唯一の手段とも言えますから
できればこうかっこよくね
もっとエレガントな
おしゃれでクールなイケメンなアイコンにしたい
そういうのってやっぱ僕が選ぶんじゃなくて
皆さんが選んだ方がいいのが手に入るんじゃないかと思いまして
今回皆さんに僕の新しいアイコン募集したいと思います
ただいま時刻が朝の3時40分です
皆起きてるかなー？
よしこれでいいでしょう
ファイア
さあこれで皆さんからどんなアイコンが来るかですね
しばらく待ってみましょう
”日常”っていうアニメがあるんですけど
僕それ大好きで
そこにいそうな顔をした僕っぽいキャラクターアイコンです
可愛い
めっちゃ気に入ってるんですけど、やっぱね
実写の方が誰かっていうのがわかりやすいんで
さあ見ていきましょう
うにいくら丼
あぁん？？
うわあうわあっああ
*口で効果音作成中*
*ビートボックス*
皆ありがとう
マシなやつが無いぞ、まずい
俺はもっとこうエレガントでクールなアイコンにしたいが
皆　なんで　笑いに　走るの？
いやありがたいっす
ありがたいんですけどこれだと決めやばいよ決めらんないよ
もう俺じゃない人ばっかりだよ
めちゃくちゃだよ
俺こんな顔したことあったけ
これは彼の祖母ですね
画質良いな
難しーなー
なかなか難しいですよねでもアイコンって
*笑*
懐かしいなこれ
顔ふざけたのしかないのかなー
「これだ！」っていうアイコンがなかなかないですね
これねこれいいねこれ
でもこれだと
なんで僕腕をこうしてるか、あっ服も同じだわ
これだとなんで僕腕をこうしてるか分からないんで
これにしましょう
これをもうちょっと付け足して
なんかこの右腕がちょっと気に食わないので
右腕になにか持たせたりこれをカスタマイズしたやつを新しいアイコンにします
さあ皆さんこれに何を持たせてくれるのでしょうか
あ、ラーメンか
ラーメンもいいですね
全体的に俺じゃねーわ
全部トミックさんだわ
おー学生の頃を思い出す
バスケットボールいいですね
やめとけやｗ
杉田玄白の解体新書に怒られるわ
夢と希望を持ってる
なぜ俺の顔をまたこれに戻した
やめろ
誰？誰を持ってるんだ
かかってんじゃねぇかｗ
元気玉です
あー悪くない
かっこいい、これちょっといいかもしれないです
すげー、強制的にもやしを載せた感
コーラ飲めるまでもうすぐなんですよね
やめろー俺の中学校の時のアルバムだ
あーこういうのいいと思うんすよ
すごい、これしっくり来てると思う
おおーかっこいい
*笑*
雑すぎて好き
よくこんなの思いつくね
ニンジン5本で指を作ってくれてますね
使いずらそうですね
阿修羅みたいになってるね
でもなんかよく見たらかっこよく見えて来たぞ
すごいな、遊戯王カードの融合みたいになってる
何これ？
うに?!
皆大好きi-Tunesカード
たしかに課金しそうな顔してますが
すごい気持ち悪かった
ww合体してる
おーーあっあっあっ
これちょっとあり保存しとこ
めちゃくちゃ面白いのも多いんですけどやっぱ純粋に剣持ってるとかっこいいな
おおライトセイバーか、いいねー
大根
なんで自分の脇押さえてる
かっこいいぞこれ
ちょっとかっこいい
雷あり
なんかそれっぽい顔してるからちょっと怖いわ
俺が盗まれた車のマフラーを持っている
もうなんかホントこれはもう狂気を感じるね
なんかアニメのアニメのキャッチみたいになってる
（ｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞｺﾞ）
まあそれっぽいけど
すごい南国っぽいとこでPPAPやってるし
皆さんセンスが素晴らしいですよ
おい死んでるわ
すごい想像力だねここまで来ると
力を貯めてる系ね
ありです、これもすごい良いと思う
これかわいいな
しがみついてるのいいですね
ありがとう
懐かしーこれ
昔オイラが作った鎌を持ってるね
*笑*
はいというわけで
こんな夜遅くに
僕のしょうもないアイコンの画像を作ってくださって
本当に皆さまありがとうございます
全部紹介できなかったんですけども、かなりたくさんのアイコンが届きました
というわけで次から僕のTwitterのアイコンはこちらになります
面白かった
しばらくはこのTwitterのアイコンでやっていきたいと思います
まだひょっとしたらTwitterやってない人いるかもしれないんで
こちら僕のTwitterでございます
気分でひょっとしたら僕とお話ができるかもしれないので
よかったら皆さんTwitterの方もフォローしといてください
これであとは美容室に行って髪の毛を整えるだけだ！
じゃあな！